Nvidia has shown that it it doesn't care
that much there's some 30 series stuff
go buy that if you want it you peasants
otherwise up here for the nonp we have
the 40
series when int Arc launched I remember
talking to one of the people I respect
the most in this industry he's highly
technical brilliant technical analyst
and it's David caner and he's been
interviewed on this channel before but
David said to me Intel doesn't have to
be number one uh it just has to be
second place he said Intel won't take
market share from Nvidia it's going to
take it from AMD and he was absolutely
right Intel Arc has been competing at
the more budget end of cards since it
launched and that's exactly what Intel
has to do because it's battling from a
weaker position Nvidia has shown that it
doesn't compete there many years ago an
Nvidia employee told me when I asked
about how do you intend to compete with
these AMD price cuts of whatever card it
was he said Steve we don't compete on
price we compete on quality and Nvidia
with the modern 40 series its lowest
card for price is a 460 at $300 so Intel
and AMD are the ones who are in the
closest competition at this we'll call
it budget end of the market these days
flexible use the word there mid-range uh
but AMD is the one that really has to
fight hard and interestingly AMD has
been fighting pretty hard against
nvidia's $700 $800 class card so things
are changing a little bit where they're
all starting to fall into their own
place and Intel is the one we're
focusing on today because the launch of
Ark was abysmal it was the worst GPU
launch that we have ever covered and it
was all because of the drivers our
immediate concerns were that Intel would
kill the projects before it could fix
the drivers that corporate management
would lose faith in it late last year we
Revisited Arc for drivers and we saw
that they had improved a lot and now
we're revisiting performance now that
the market has adjusted uh and shipped
the rest of the cards at least for now
in the refreshes so our early
conclusions were that when it worked the
hardware was competitive but it was the
when it worked that was problematic
because we couldn't recommend something
that works sometimes really well and
other times not at all uh that has
slowly been shifting and now going on
almost 2 years later we feel a little
more comfortable recommending Arc to a
slightly wider group of users this huge
list of patch notes were showing is just
one of the two most recent drivers Intel
published similar sized updates for over
a year now and that's dangerous for AMD
and Nvidia whenever they're competing in
a similar price class to Intel's Arc
cart because AMD and nvidia's drivers
are so impressively mature and
established already that there's little
extra juice to squeeze out of driver
updates and that's where we think AMD is
almost more threatened right now at this
range of the market than Nvidia is
NVIDIA has shown that it doesn't care
that much there's some 30 series stuff
go buy that if you want it you peasants
otherwise up here for the non-pes we
have the 40 series and that leaves AMD
which oddly again has been fighting
harder at the 7900 XT Mark than down
here so let's look into it before that
this video is brought to you by thermal
Grizzly and the cryos sheet graphine
pads these cryos sheets are molecularly
stacked in the z-axis to encourage
vertical direct thermal transfer from
the IHS to the cooler cryo sheet pads
are made to be easily applicable for a
thermal interface and completely avoid
past dry out because it's not paced it
makes them particularly useful for lawn
service life systems with minimal
maintenance they come in multiple sizes
for suitability on the most common
laptops and desktop CPUs and you can
learn more at the thermal Grizzly cryo
sheets at the link in the description
below today's testing will be focused on
the improvements for Intel Arc we're
looking at the a770 the a750 the a580 we
have A380 results in there as well uh
it's not really the key Focus today but
they're in there if you care about them
we're testing with the latest 5252
drivers that are supposed to further
bolster performance in several games and
these were preceded by 5234 not a huge
change between them in fact in most
instances there's zero change uh it's
just that there were some iterative
improvements with 5252 for Starfield so
we added those and they both offer a
huge list of dx11 improvements and some
dx12 improvements Intel's biggest
challenges have been directx9 and
DirectX 11 and they really focused on
directx9 dx11 has been the next Focus so
that's supporting those older games and
anything coming out today that's been
development for long enough to use
either uh Intel's also changed how it's
running dx9 uh or is working on changing
and how it's running dx11 we'll have
news for you soon on that and some of
the technical details of it that should
improve as well but the video today will
be a mix of benchmarks and some talking
head commentary just for fun to talk
about where things are right now because
we think this is a lot more interesting
than what Nvidia and AMD have sh out for
the last month pricing is a good
starting point so let's start there with
some quick browsing here's the update on
the relevant part of the market in US
pricing the Intel rcade 770 16 gigb
model which is what we're testing these
days is typically around $290 to $300
a750 has its cheapest entry at $25 at
least at the time of writing uh a
sparkle variant that we tested is at 210
and plenty of others are in the $220
range the 750 has been the card we've
tended to recommend the most out of
Intel's current lineup and that's been
because of the value the a580 is pric at
$165 at the lowest with other options at
$180 with new Egon Amazon listings the
A380 is priced at around $120 these days
with the A310 the only card not tested
today since it's too lowend for these
tests at around $90 to $110 for
competition the RTX 460 is nvidia's
cheapest and most relevant 40 series
card priced at around $300 to 320 the
4060 TI 8 GB is still around $400 and is
in a substantially different price class
from Intel's options today the 3050 is
around 250 bucks these days for the 8 GB
model and will underperform every single
one of these cars we've mentioned so far
except the A380 and the 3056 GB doesn't
count there's also the 3060 at $285 for
AMD it's mostly the 7600 at $260 the
7600 XT the brand new car at
$330 and the RX 6600 from last gen but
still a great value at $200 the 6600 XT
is around $2 40 bucks also a pretty good
value the past year and the 6650 XT
refresh is at 250 so those 6600 series
cards are going to be the most relevant
from amd's price to Performance
standpoint while the 7600 is it's most
relevant from the newest standpoint so
there's a surprising amount of cards in
this price class actually if you really
look at it it's just that most of them
are from AMD and from Intel the AMD
part's not surprising Intel is obviously
the the new one to arrive to this part
of the market but Nvidia has only one
modern option that's anywhere close to
this price class and uh again the 3050 6
GB technically is a new card but it has
cut down cores it is slower for
frequency a lot uh and uh it it doesn't
count so it's 4060 is the closest
relevant one other than last gen stuff
where it's kind of the 3060 and we have
that in the charts as well for the
charts today we have cut the high-end
from them to make space for all these
cards so the 490 480 480 super 700 XTX
those have been removed the 6950 in a
lot of instances removed if you want
those numbers check our 480 uh super or
actually you get more numbers in the 470
TI super review and that'll give you the
high end we've also just published the
article versions of our super reviews on
Gamers access.net and this will join
them in a few days so you can check it
out there as a reminder that's an adree
version of all of our reviews absolutely
no thirdparty banner ads so it loads
stupidly fast as a result it's single
page no jumping through a ton of pages
for review and if you want fast answers
on Hardware performance check out the
site it's all entirely funded by you all
so to support our adree written reviews
and to support the benchmarking that
happens here in the videos head over to
store. Gamers nexus.net and please
consider grabbing one of our comfortable
t-shirts with PC component designs our
silicone soldering and project mats with
extreme heat resistance or our GN 3D
emblem glass the 15th anniversary
edition which has a super cool metal
emblem on the glass you can find all
that on the store let's get into the
testing Resident Evil 4 had the Intel
a750 at 4 to 105 FPS average which is
about tied with the RX 6600 XT and RX
7600 gpus it's a great place for the
a750 to start and at a lower price than
the RX 7600 it's also competitive the
a770 pushes up to 116 FPS average
leading the brand new freshly launched
$330 RX 7600 XT by 5.2% while costing
$40 less as for NVIDIA its last genen
3060 TI is about equal while the new
4060 about $10 more than an a770 falls
behind in this chart it's remarkable
comparative performance for Intel for
the a580 we saw 91 FPS average that
ranked it between the RX 6600 currently
still available for 190 to 20000 bucks
and the RTX 2070 super it's not distant
either from the goated 1080 TI and
finally the A380 is predictably at the
bottom of the chart it's the lowest end
card we've tested any time recently so
we need to add the GT 1030 or gtx650
class cards to compare closer at 1440p
the a750 and a770 remain in completely
playable territory despite the increas
in graphic strain the a580 is also
playable here although depending on your
preferences maybe just barely the A380
predictably can't handle this and the
important comparisons go like this the
a750 runs about 72 FPS average tied with
the brand new significantly more
expensive 7600 XT which falls in
relative position in this test from The
increased pixel processing load that
means the 7600 XT is 57% more expensive
than the a750 for equivalent performance
so in other words yikes the RX 7600
meanwhile is also functionally tied but
it still costs more as for NVIDIA the
4060 allows Intel a lead of almost 5%
but Intel maintains the cost Advantage
the a580 also punches above its weight
class landing at 62 FPS average and
leading the RX 6600 by 7% and finally
the a770 leads the 7600 XT by about 9%
with the 4060 TI leading the a770 more
notably at about 14% at 4K the a770
doesn't quite make it to playable
territory without any upscaling
assistance or lower settings
comparatively it's now about equal to
the 4060 TI though which has shifted
down due to weaknesses in places like
memory bandwidth we talked about that
with the 460 TI review we're moving on
to Rainbow Six Siege this game was the
bane of int's existence at launch
posting some of the worst performance
we'd seen for this level of Hardware
ever it was so so bad that Rainbow 6 was
one of the first titles that Intel
specifically targeted for improvement
prompting follow-up testing where we
actually did see the parts start to
improve for the first time in today's
updated chart though in first at 4K the
A50 runs at 79 FPS average and roughly
ties both the 4060 and the 7600 in
average 1% .1% Lads given that it's
cheaper than both that's another strong
position for Intel especially with the
frame time pacing now being fixed the
a770 sits between the 6700 XT which
outpaces the 7600 XT and the RTX 460 TI
the a770 is lead over the 7600 XT is 8%
with a lead of 10% over the 4060 and the
4060 TI leads the a770 by 12% similar to
last time just for perspective we have
two a580 entries on this chart that's
intentional other cards haven't changed
nearly as much but Intel has and that
indicates that Intel's improvements
largely came from its drivers not just
the game which itself has updated the
old a580 result had it at 36 FPS average
with completely unplayable and highly
inconsistent loads the frame time pacing
was bad the new drivers have brought
that up to an impressive 68 FPS or a 91%
improvement shows how much power the
drivers have when they're not as mature
as Nvidia are the lows have gone from
broken to actually consistent and that
pulls it ahead of the 6600 at 1440p the
int Arc cards fall in the ranks
comparatively they're doing a lot better
at 4K against the competition the a750
here though outperforms the RX 6600 XT
by 5.3% but the 7600 leads the a750 by
133% up at 177 FPS average the a770 also
doesn't scale as strongly here roughly
tying the 4060 and falling behind the
7600 that odd behavior continues at
1080p where Intel struggles to keep rank
with its normal competition the r 7600
now leads the a750 by around 25% which
is a massive change the a770 is is also
behind the RTX 460 and the RX 7600 at
least they're playable but this does
illustrate ark's weakness as being its
General unpredictability at times DL 2
at 1440p the $290 Arc a770 Rivals the
$400 460 TI the latter of which has an
advantage of only
7% despite a price increase of
38% against the 7600 XT the a770 manages
a lead not only in better pricing but in
outright performance with a 10%
Advantage the a750 is roughly tied with
the 7600 XT the 4060 and the 7600
meaning the primary differentiating
factor between these in this game is
price and as for the a580 it's
competitive with the 6600 XT here which
is a good spot for it to be at 1080p the
4060 climbs and equals the a770 GPU the
7600 isn't far behind the a750
approaches the 7600 levels of
performance but has clearly Fallen
somewhat from its higher resolution
rankings Final Fantasy at 4K the a770
runs at about 56 FPS average which has
it 5% ahead of the RTX 460 the 460 leads
the a750 by 9% AMD 7600 XT is about tied
with the a750 doing it no favors in a
price battle finally the a580 is now
about equal to the 6600 XT at 1440p the
a770 is tied with the 4060 in all
metrics leading the 7600 XT and the 7600
the a750 is perceptibly equal to the
7600 from a user experience standpoint
although with technically better 1% Lads
and the a580 is flanked by the 6600 and
the 360 Intel is competing with its
similarly classed Parts here that's all
it needs to do at 1080p a wider Gap
forms again so this seems to be a trend
between some games with Intel the 4060
at 190 FPS average now leads the a770 by
3.7% the a770 is about tied with the
7600 for average FPS now it's only only
advantage in this chart is price this
time in an absolute sense the a580 and
the A380 are both playable here in the
very least unfortunately for Intel it's
sometimes just completely broken GTA 5
appears to be one of those times in this
test none of the Intel cards could get
out of the 30fps range when running with
these settings you can still get the
frame rate higher but you have to drop
the settings and the resolution and the
point here is that they are deviating
from what we expected from all the other
results so based on the previous charts
the a770 should be at least up around 50
FPS if not closer to 60 but it's just
not doing it here Starfield is another
one that's specifically broken in a
sense on Arc and they know this in fact
their latest driver was supposed to fix
this but we're not seeing the fix we
tried these drivers and the ones that
predate them one revision as well and
both produced to the same result
unfortunately for Arc its performance it
mirrors that of GTA 5s in the prior test
and it's just clearly broken it runs but
the RTX 4060 has has a frame rate
multiples faster with the 7600 also
boosted Way Beyond what we've seen in
other games it's instances like these
that hurt arc's wide reaching viability
and these are the only reasons we
hesitate when answering whether or not
someone should buy arc our R tracing
tests are next and these are actually
really interesting for Arc some of these
games are shared with the earlier ones
for rasterized tests but for RT we use
different settings obviously and they're
not directly comparable as an
interesting not as while RT Hardware is
available even on the A310 it won't run
well for most applications but the
hardware is there that could be useful
somewhere but we'll start with cyberpunk
and 1080p medium RT settings without
upscaling if you want to use upscaling
to boost the performance go for it but
for purposes of comparing two devices by
relative performance this is what we
want in this test the a770 ran at 38 FPS
average and held strong lows that were
proportional to the average you would
want upscaling or reduced settings to
get a more stable experience here but
again our goals are to compare in the
relative sense the RTX 460
outperformance the A7 70 by 3.4% putting
Intel dangerously close to Nvidia when
considering nvidia's General advantage
in RT workloads and in fact the a770 has
stronger 0.1% low performance that we'll
see in a frame time plot in a moment the
4060 has more sporadic performance and
frame time pacing with these settings
than we typically see the a750 allowed
the 4060 an 18% Advantage so a big gap
from the 770 but it still managed a
significant lead over the RX 7600 this
Frame time plot shows the raw frame to
frame interval in milliseconds or time
required to render a frame as presented
in its base metric of time we're
currently showing two passes of the RTX
460 here you can see that one of the
passes had several spikes higher than 50
milliseconds the other pass has one bad
Spike to about 110 milliseconds which is
1/10th of a second that you'd be staring
at the same frame so that's a pretty big
spike the a770 is much more consistent
and lacks any of these massive spikes
that's how the 0.1% lows are supposed to
be used used in our FPS charts they're
an indicator as a bar that points us
towards a problem we can represent as a
line and here the problem is the 40's
ability to consistently deliver well Ed
frames 10p Ultra is where we see Nvidia
really pull ahead of AMD with
unbelievably large gaps that illustrate
how higher RT loads will
disproportionately benefit Nvidia
performance despite being unplayable the
raw performance shows that Intel manages
to keep up better than AMD does price
for Price Arc is impressive 28 FPS
average result for the a770 still with
relatively flat frame times has it close
to an RX 7700 XT that's a $290 Intel
card competing with a $420 to $450 AMD
card the lead over the RX 7600 XT model
for the a770 is 46% here with the a750
leading the RX 7600 base model by 58%
the a750 also manages to maintain more
proportional frame times than the RX
7600 00 which sees them diverge from the
average more noticeably as for why Intel
does so well in cyberpunk specifically
Intel's Tom Peterson provided some
engineering Insight when we asked why
and he said this quote in cyberpunk we
see good results from the BBH cache
since a large fraction of the time in
that app with rt heavy workloads we're
walking bbh's it also is likely that the
thread sorting unit is helping the
thread sorting unit is a physical piece
of hardware on the GPU while BBH cash is
an area where Intel has spent
significant special optimization effort
we'll talk more about these in future
topics and Video in Resident Evil 4 at
1080p with rt and using quality FSR the
a770 landed at about 84 FPS average and
equated the RX 7600 although it
maintained better frame time consistency
in the 0.1% lows the RTX 460 leads the
a770 by 14.6% here with a750 tying the
2070 this game is a lighter RT workload
so AMD is able to recover its position
in this particular title we see similar
behavior in games like Tomb Raider with
rt where only one RT feature is actually
used we're including 1440p here because
it reinforces an earlier point the a770
is able to gain ground on the RTX 460 in
this test which has its lead reduced
from 15% in the 1080p charge to just one
so a big jump and the resolution bump is
hard for the 4060 and 460 TI cards to
handle at this scale dlight 2 is
significantly heavier as an RT workload
than Resident Evil 4 and tends to have
wider gaps between AMD and Nvidia at
1080p the a770 ran at 66 FPS average and
actually managed to technically outmatch
the 4060 the a750 follows with the 7600
and its 46 FPS average just an
afterthought the a750 is lead over the
7600 is 30% here at 1440p the a770 is
slightly ahead of the RTX 460 again with
the a750 just behind and these RX 7600
series cards are dragging behind here as
well as usual we have have plenty more
data and games we've tested you can find
most of those in our 7600 XT review our
4070 TI super review uh they have more
games packed into them and most of these
Arc results well the cards are present
just they've gotten updated a little
more since then uh but you can find even
more there if you really want it the
point is though that the trend in all
the games matches the trend of what we
showed today it kind of encapsulates
everything where sometimes it works
phenomenally well and we're really
impressed by how much ground they've
gained and other times it's still just
functionally utterly broken which is
unfortunate so uh outside of gaming
Intel still has some challenges we
didn't talk about and those can be with
power consumptions so for example The
Arc cards have relatively high idle
power consumption uh and that's
something we talked about in our driver
update video where we did the revisit
one year later about a month or or I
guess two three months ago now
additionally under load frame for frame
Intel is less efficient than Nvidia it's
maybe not a surprise amd's in the same
boat uh but if it's something you really
really care about then Intel is weaker
there and we think there has to be a
priorities list for GPU manufacturers
when they're in a position like Intel is
where it it's not only the underdog but
it's brand new to this market and it's
fighting another Underdog because if you
can't run games or you struggle with it
like GTA like Starfield like they did
with Counter Strike at the beginning
that's fixed now uh then none of it
matters doesn't matter how power
efficient it is it's it's infinitely
power efficient if there's zero FPS uh
or actually maybe maybe infinitely power
inefficient depends how you want to
divide by zero there but the point is
we've separately deep dived into Intel's
Arc drivers on the software suite as
recently as again a couple months ago
and when we did that revisit we found
that they had massively improved and
we'll link that below um if you want to
learn more about it or you can read it
on the website as for conclusions
they're pretty simple when Intel Arc
works it works exceptionally well for
the price that it is the this is a stark
change from the initial launch when we
uh bashed it for having several games
that were completely broken stuttered in
unplayable ways had a driver package
that would crash when you clicked on
buttons as if no one had ever used the
software at Intel so that so far has
been fixed they had all kinds of
blurring and artifacting mess that
happened as a result of their special
features and much of that has been
resolved it seems Arc is still somewhat
binary but it's a lot better despite its
strong performance it either works in
which case it's a scary competitor for
AMD more than it is for NVIDIA or it's
functionally broken and stuck at frame
rates that are so low as to be
Irrelevant in this round of tests though
the amount of times it was broken is far
lower than we've seen for our numerous
revisits over the past year we are at
two titles that performed really poorly
in this round of tests and that's out of
14 games that we tested in total when
including the unpublished tests so two
of 14 it's not a good percentage but
both are on older engines and maybe
there's a link there we do think that
Intel remains in a class of buyers where
it should probably be someone with
Enthusiast level knowledge however it's
slowly exiting that class and becoming
something that can be recommended to a
slightly more mainstream level so where
we draw a line is somewhere like if you
have a family member who wants to build
a PC and they have either no patience or
time for
pcbs uh or it is someone who has
absolutely no troubleshooting
capabilities or a mix of the two
probably you don't tell them to buy an
a750 uh if you don't want to deal with
the problems when they arise but we do
think that this is now in some type of
category between hardcore enthusiasts
and mainstream so whatever you might
call that Slimmer group of users maybe
the word is just patient and the good
news is that the patience isn't getting
tested nearly as much as it was 18
months ago as for RT Intel is
competitive with AMD and it's
outclassing it in some scenarios Nvidia
still holds significant advantages and
overwhelmingly RT heavy titles like
cyberp Punk but once again Intel is
competing in sometimes stronger ways
than AMD is and that's where we think a
lot of this story is going for Value the
a750 has held strong recommendations
when it occasionally drops to 180 bucks
that was crazy when it did that but even
at 210 we think it makes sense to buy
now it's starting to clear some of those
hurdles for a lot of our audience if
you're spending $200 it really makes
sense to seriously consider Ark now the
a770 is also posting better value now
that its price has fallen below $300 and
certainly it puts some pressure on the
4060 and 7600 XT we still want to be
extremely clear though which is that
Intel Arc still has problems and those
problems when they happen are the kind
that are frustrating because there's
really not much you can do about it and
it's not just like the the performance
isn't quite as good as a competitor it's
like the performance is half or worse of
a competitor uh a lot of the frame time
pacing problems have been fixed so at
least it's not stuttering as hard in
those situations but we're talking half
the frame rate it probably should be
it's not a good feeling and the big
caveat is that it doesn't happen a whole
lot but the reason I feel the need to
keep saying it is because I need the
audience need you all to be aware of it
where we do think it's a good value but
the times it doesn't work it's going to
suck it's just that those times aren't
as much as they used to be overall
though we are hugely impressed with the
performance improvements that Intel has
posted the if you go look at the driver
patch notes the length of some of those
lists uh shows that there is an active
effort to continue improving hopefully
the uh recent rounds of layoffs at Intel
and other tech companies but Intel here
haven't affected the driver development
team in a way that's going to really
slow things because that's where they
need their focus uh the drivers as we
showed improved a lot for usability for
the interface but now it's on continuing
to push the performance um and we think
they're doing well there so anyway we
have an active project right now we're
doing some PC build guides again first
time in a while so some of those use
Intel Arc we've got AMD and Nvidia
follow-ups for people who want to just
have that guaranteed I don't want to
deal with anything weird at all uh we're
going to be working on build guides for
each of those so really excited about it
check back for that subscribe for it go
to store. Gamers access.net if you want
to support our testing efforts directly
and buy something like one of our
gn15 glasses with metal emblem on it
thanks for watching we'll see you all
next time